now the question that's tormenting us
why's George Clooney being blamed for
trimming the profits of a men's grooming
Brown we're going to find out in just a
moment as we take a look through the
business pages of all the Sunday papers
with the broadcaster and businesswoman
Margaret Manfred and the PR guru and
co-founder of Seven Hills he's Michael
Heyman and be iliyan congratulations or
you can see you how many such a good
time in the green room and call you Mick
and man come on enlighten us so what's
George Clooney done well apparently he
grew a beard and so a lot of other
people thought they would - including
Paxman whether he was trying to emulate
we don't know but this has affected
sales of razors worldwide and there's
actually a large article it further
inside the the Telegraph not just a
front-page bit with will King who's the
king of shave new razor which apparently
is supposed to glide effortlessly across
the stubble presumably taking the
stubble with it based on catheter
technology actually it's supposed to be
we're going to that no no we don't wanna
go into that but we wondered whether
whether you were going to set a trip
down with the holiday be Paxman got away
with it mean it has it had a serious
effect I mean we're seeing obviously
just one of those rather silly stories
or has that had a real serious effect on
the bottom line I think it probably has
had a bit of effect or maybe the maybe
there's just a trend and that's part of
it and you can say that that's that's
the cause but there may be the effect
it's the war of the shapes I mean he's a
he's a big I mean I know working very
well I mean he's he's at he's a man he's
a man for campaigning and you know he's
got sort of Gillette's in his in his
gaze but actually there is this other
big social trend which is we're becoming
a hairier nation I guess I mean people
aren't shaving as we see with a lot of
younger men yeah but portsmen I shared
it officer it was also 2013 it's over
wow yeah well that's a new year
opportunities now your first story
Michael is so retailers in fight back
after supermarkets hit and some of them
had a pretty bad Christmas period I know
I mean I was just thinking about this I
mean it feels like this story is more
changeable than the weather at the
moment in one minute it's sort of dark
clouds and then it's a bit of blue skies
I mean and I think that's partly because
we are in this very very interesting
period where with the beginnings of an
economic recovery and of course not all
the stories are great but whereas last
week was very much about the sort of
them the food supermarkets and showing
some really to fairly sort of poor
results this week it's all about the
retailers and what they're doing and
what you're seeing is is that there's a
battle on the high street but I think
the most important trend has got to be
the online revolution where the UK is
the number one online trading nation in
the world for consumer purchases and
those that don't get that are going to
get left behind I mean there was
particularly that growth though it
wasn't there of click and Collect
whereas you know you if you're not in
you still get it you don't have to go
down the sorting office or bring up UPS
or DHL whoever it is and say come on
another day yeah huge growth in that and
it makes you wonder what's going to
happen to all these enormous out-of-town
hypermarkets because if people are going
to just want a warehouse to go and pick
up something they've ordered online and
and maybe the high street will start to
come back as we get smaller retailers
with fresh produce people still want to
go and buy themselves and all the big
stuff will get ordered online never not
interesting all these retailing trends
Margaret you've got this story that said
the Americans another British brown
taking a big bite of Hovis another
really old British band
I mean 125 years of red wedding who
wondered if it was that old I know the
advertising it tries to make
it certainly was in the 70s and that's
practically 125 but it's a bit of a
shame if you think that another
old-style long-standing British brand is
going to America and there's wonderful
photograph of Alex Gore sitting in
between some actresses and models none
of whom ever look as if they've eaten a
slice of bread in their bodies
absolutely and he's quite a character
this guy but I think it comes in to
another interesting fact which is that
you know how brands sort of go up and
down and what you see is that other sort
of bread brands like Kings will have
been getting it nailed on gluten-free
and all sorts of other sorts of things
and Havis is right for a for a makeover
and by the looks of this guy he's a bit
of a character professional poker player
lots of sort of things that he sort of
bringing I guess to the table and an
Havis will be shaken up one way to go
from those ads where they were on a very
heavy steel bike Michael you got this
story I mean it's much discussed of
course about erm wages and of course
wage has been lagging inflation for a
long time even yeah treasury
conservative thinks the minimum wage
could go up yeah I think in many ways
this is the story of the weekend which
is the low pay Commission they're about
to go into three days of perda where
they're going to consider whether the
sort of living wage needs to rise and
whether this is minimum wage because
minimum wage inflation they conflated
into TVs but the minimum wage you're
right the the minimum wages which
currently stands about six pounds 31 I
think it is is whether it goes up and
what you have is a it's probably some
level of consensus in business that it
is right for change but certainly not a
consensus that it could go up to some of
the sort of levels of some of the some
of the politicians are talking about I
think that yeah what you've got is a
very very mixed picture in the UK
economy at the moment where London could
probably take it but there are large
parts of the UK economy certainly many
people in small businesses that would be
very very concerned at this stage to
changes in the minimum wage because it
is a huge political debate with labour
shifting their attack as the economy
picked up Margaret to know this cost of
living who is feeling the benefits of
recovery well an increase in the in the
minimum wage would make a difference
that political argument it would it
would also make a difference they say or
some say to the benefits bill because
according to the Institute of Fiscal
Studies for every pound the minimum wage
goes up fifty P is saved on benefits
because of course the minimum wage is
not a living wage and an awful lot of
people earning the minimum wage are also
getting tax credits or other forms of
income support from the Treasury so so
in a way in the minimum having a low
minimum wage is subsidizing particular
employers but the government isn't
having a choice in which employers
subsidizing in that way yeah but it's
interesting is that the you know in a
way it's also a fairly healthy debate
because I think it shows that you know
businesses gain beyond just the survival
point and actually some of these social
debates coming social cost debates come
on is as of what is acceptable and you
know and I think that there is there is
some acknowledgement that licit this is
probably a needle that needs to be
pushed a little bit up okay and on that
note we'll only thank you very much
indeed
Michael Margaret make a match very good
to see you thank you very much Cindy
Claire taking us through the business
page of the Sunday papers there